ce matin les footballeur de l'as
saint-etienne ont participé à leur
premier entraînement
dix neuf joueurs étaient présents
manquaient à l'appel les réfractaires
françois ott wisnieski et richard
tylinski mais aussi les transférer guy
cassado courbon balboa vega et de
nouilhan l'entraîneur jean snella a
retrouvé la plupart de ses joueurs en
bonne forme par exemple de mijak est qui
remplacera fériés pierre bernard qui est
plus que jamais un exemple pour les
jeunes
robert herbin qui veut conserver le
capitanat de l'équipe de france rachid
mekhloufi qui seront concernés le
stratège des verts
nello spies qui posera des problèmes aux
attaquants adverses
paul denis qui doit éclater
littéralement cette saison le board à ce
qui sera un élément précieux au milieu
du terrain
salen est toujours aussi vif argent
mitoraj confirmera ses excellentes
dispositions quant à rené férié nous lui
souhaitons de réussir à bastia donc
bonne chance à tous et rendez vous le 21
août à 16 heures pour le premier match
contre nîmes